[Musique]
pour mathieu norme pour un mec qui fait
de la muscu t'as pas honte de tête chie
dessus devant tony yoka 1 c'est pas faux
oui c'est vrai que c'était y'a ville il
y avait le champion olympique de boxe
était avec nous mon pote tony yoka on a
la vidéo d'ailleurs regardez stèle
mosley et tonino cateau les champions
alain buts contre jean mi attention
c'est parti
vous avez plus grands
sans rien abandonner leur donner le
temps d'une enquête alors mais on dit
tout oui depuis que j'ai battu rohff
j'suis la terreur des banlieues ouais
c'est dire la vérité aux amateurs de
quelle banlieue
non je suis très très respecté c'est
vrai donc tony hawk a maintenant ils
vous respectent pas franchement je suis
très très respecté à la fois du coup on
est devenus potes patrons savent que ça
y'est quoi ils savent qui je suis ouais
savent qu'on est amis comme telle et non
mais j'aurais voile aujourd'hui tony
hawk agents non face à tony j'avoue dit
toute la vérité face à tony j'ai perdu
j'ai pas être montré un courage énorme
dans cette séquence dure que maintenant
c'est mon seul échec
c'est face à un champion olympique oui
pardon aux médias bill gates peur de lui
ou pas franchement voilà il est
sympathique et souriant maintenant
j'avoue que je ne connais pas du tout et
il est énervé ah oui là j'avoue que vous
avez pas de wasquehal a en fait il est
là il en mais non mais non non mais il
est pas là c'est pas vrai il ya ben
alaya voilà il peut pas bien
[Applaudissements]
alors à l'oni c'est la terreur des
banlieues ouais c'est vrai ou pas de
quoi j respecter un moment donné dans
les banlieues pas du tout banni
[Applaudissements]
respecter ou même si ma mission respecte
pas il m'a salée faites vous voulez
faire un petit bisou à tony pour vous
excuser de ce que vous avez fait d'être
à la fois parce que vous l'avez un peu
taper à ça et beaucoup de plaisir mais
on a mis en ami mais c'est ma femme et
les jalouses de leurs mots et sa femme
non mais c'est vrai qu'un amour d'être
venu moto ni voilà
energy canada sur la joue enfin
évidemment c'est du passé en futaie de
la situation sur toi ta vie ta demande
bien passé mais je tape les stèles tu as
pleuré